[Music]
uh okay great thank you so much so I'm
going to be talking about new techniques
for zero knowledge leveraging
inefficient provers to reduce
assumptions and traction and Trust
um and this is a joint work with
Marshall ball uh who may be there I'm
not sure and
um sorry it's really hard to see hard to
see anyone
um and McCool Kulkarni
um okay so I assume everyone here knows
about nizics uh and also I know the last
talk was about nizics so I won't
actually Define nizzix
um but I will talk just a little bit
about the landscape of uh nizzix for NP
because there's like a lot of moving
Parts here and it's gonna be a little
bit important to keep track of the
different uh parameters
um so there's various things that we can
look at we can look at whether the
honest prover is efficient or
inefficient
um we can look at whether the soundness
guarantee is either computational or
statistical we can look at whether the
zero knowledge guarantee is
computational or statistical and we know
that we need some kind of setup and
we're going to be considering
essentially two different types of
setups so uniform reference string where
the
um
shared bits are just chosen uniformly at
random as well as a common reference
string where they can be chosen from
some other distribution
so let's just see a few examples of what
is known to be achievable and I
apologize if I skip out any related work
there's an awful lot of work on music so
feel free to add if I if I missed
anything
um
so let's first look at the regime where
the honest prover is efficient
um and for now let's look at statistical
sadness computational zero knowledge and
a common reference string
um so in this case we have uh several
different constructions from various
assumptions
and you can see that I put the
assumptions here in the box and this box
is going to be red to kind of indicate
uh bad
um and it's not really bad but it's
going to be bad in the sense that all of
the the assumptions that I've listed
there are all known to imply a public
key encryption
um and later on we're going to be
looking at assumptions that are weaker
than that
okay so what else can we do
um well we may also not really want a
common reference string it's a little
bit preferable to have a uniform
reference string
um in that case you can use like maybe
the nist beacon
um or maybe even like a natural
phenomenon and a two-source extractor to
kind of generate
um your uniform reference strings so
that in some sense like reduces the
amount of trust that that you're going
to need
um and in this case we also we have like
lots of assumptions that we know lots of
constructions
um that we can get this from but again
you'll notice that this box is still
um all red
so these are all assumptions that imply
public key encryption
um if we switch the soundness and the
zero knowledge so computational zero
knowledge and statistic sorry
statistical zero knowledge and
computational soundness
we also know constructions
both in the common reference string and
in the uniform reference string model
um so this is all great
um but what we wanted to look in this
talk is like reducing uh assumptions
so one way that we can try to reduce
these assumptions is to actually allow
instead of having an efficient honest
perver
um we can allow the honest pervert to be
inefficient
um and now we're again going to want to
have statistical sadness and
computational zero knowledge and in this
case we have constructions in the common
reference string model uh from the kind
of minimal Assumption of one-way
functions so now this box is green
because we're able to
construct
this primitive from these weaker
assumptions
um and if we want a uniform reference
string which we said like in some sense
reduces the trust uh then we can still
do it uh and we can still do it from
these greenbox assumptions
um but now uh in the plane model uh we
only know how to do this from a one-way
permutation instead of one-way function
and the talk that we just heard was on
how to actually achieve this in the
random Oracle model in which case
they're actually is no need for a
uniform reference string at all
um so um I just want to point out an
inherent property that's going to be
coming up in the talk is that uh when we
look at these um inefficient honest
prover and these proof techniques that
we have
um kind of a main feature of this uh the
main property of these constructions is
that the honest prover is going to run
in time larger than what we allow the
zero knowledge distinguisher to run in
um and if you remember kind of the
implementation of the Hidden bits model
this is kind of the reason why because
um The Honest River has to be able to
open the hidden bits but the zero
knowledge property relies on the fact
that um the bits that weren't open
remained remain hidden
um okay so uh now I'm gonna move on from
that and I'm going to talk about a
slightly different primitive but very
related
um called zaps and again I'm going to be
looking at zaps for all of NP
um so uh the short description of a zap
is that it's a two message uh witness
and distinguishable public coin protocol
for proving that X is in an NP language
um and
um the first message from the verifier
to the proofer is just going to consist
of a bunch of random bits
um so we're going to call it row and the
message going from the proverb to the
verifier is the actual proof pi
and we have um the completeness sadness
and witness indistinguishable
indistinguishability properties
and I just want to emphasize uh for
sadness we actually have statistical
soundness which says that
um with high probability over row and
for a statement X which is not in the
language there doesn't exist a response
Pi which is going to cause the verifier
to accept
um whereas for witness and
distinguishability we're going to have a
computational property
um which says that for all first
messages rho we can actually just fix
the first message the Distribution on
the proof Pi when the prover has input
xw versus xw Prime so these are two
witnesses for the same statement are
computationally indistinguishable even
given both the witnesses
and I also want to note that since we've
been talking about inefficient provers
um this the notion of zaps becomes
trivial if either the witness is unique
so if there's only a single uh witness
for the statement X or if we allow the
proverb to be completely arbitrarily
inefficient in which case like given a
statement in the language it can always
just look for the canonical witness and
send a proof based on this canonical
Witness
um okay so uh what do we know about the
relationship between musics and zaps so
um the seminal paper that introduced
zaps by dwork and or also showed a
construction and they showed that
assuming the existence of an Isaac proof
system for a language uh L with
efficient reverse
in the uniform random string model there
exists a Zap for language L with
efficient provers
um and we're gonna be looking kind of a
little closely at this transformation in
this top and we're going to see that in
order for the security reduction to work
um in order for the security for the
computational witness and
distinguishability argument to work the
honest prover has to run in time less
than the allowed run time of the zero
knowledge distinguisher
um and so uh using this uh theorem of
dworkin or we actually have an
equivalence that goes uh both ways so um
nizik in the URS model implies X and
zaps plus one-way function also imply
nizik in the URS model
um using the fls technique uh and the
this is all only for the case of
efficient proverbs
um
okay so basically
um you know if we want to construct zaps
with efficient provers and we want to
construct it from these green
assumptions these mini Crypt assumptions
that do not imply public encryption
um were kind of a little bit dead if we
use efficient proofers because we know
that these two Notions are actually
equivalent
um and so since we don't know any
construction of um nizik with the fish
improvers from these mini Crypt
assumptions we're also not going to be
able to construct zaps
um so uh the question that we kind of
motivated us was we were asking like if
we relax the Assumption on efficient
approvers
um can we actually get meaningful
Notions of Zap uh these apps from
minicrypt assumptions and for purposes
of this talk I'm going to assume that
these are assumptions that are known to
be separated from Key agreement and
hence also uh from public key encryption
um and uh the problem as as you might
have noticed is that in the known uh
nizit constructions for many Crypt
assumptions the honest prover has to run
in time greater than the allowed runtime
of the zero knowledge distinguisher and
this kind of contradicts the property
that we needed in order for the dworkin
or security reduction to go through
um so uh in this work we we tried to get
around that
um and what we did is we showed that
assuming the existence of a nizzic proof
system
for a language out with provers running
in time t
uh in the URS model there exists a Zap
for oh with proofers running and time
poly n times T where n is security
parameter so we were able to
um
get around this uh drawback of the
original dworkin or construction and
note that in our theorem there is no
restriction on how T relates to the
allowed run time of the zero knowledge
um distinguisher however note that the
theorem is vacuous if T is enough time
to find all Witnesses because in that
case we have unconditional zaps
um and a corollary of this theorem is
that assuming when we permutations there
exists steps for NP with sub-exponential
time provers
so we can get zaps for all of NP
um without having these trivial
approvers that can break every NP
language
um another advantage of constructing
zaps is that we can try to further
introduce further reduce the trust and
further reduce the interaction
so um what if we just fully want to get
rid of the URS uh and just uh and also
get rid of the two messages in the zap
um well it turns out that we can
leverage
um a result of uh Barack Ang and Varan
to show that assuming uh one-way
permutations and hitting set generators
um for code non-deterministic circuits
there exists non-interactive witness and
distinguishable approvers uh proofs niwi
for NP with sub-exponential time provers
so we can actually change the two round
uh or two message protocol into just a
one message protocol
um and we can also
um go one step further and if we assume
the above as well as sub-exponential
secure uniform Collision resistant hash
functions then we can get some kind of
notion of uh offline uh music
um in the no setup model so we don't
need uh any setup at all uh where the
simulator
this notion says that the simulator is
efficient after a pre-processing stage
and before seeing the statement
however the entire simulator is not a
polynomial time
okay so those are the results and um for
the rest of the talk I'm going to uh
recap the dworkin or transformation
which
um I assume many people are probably
familiar with
um and then we'll see the issue with uh
having an inefficient honest approval
algorithm
um and then we'll get around that we'll
present a new construction
um and then I probably I'm guessing I
won't have time but uh if there's time
I'll also discuss a new definition of a
fine-grained nizik that we introduced in
this work as well as observing that our
transformation also works in the fine
grain setting
um and then finally I'll wrap up with uh
future directions
okay so
um the initial transformation of dork
and or it starts with um a nizik in the
URS model and is trying to construct a
zap
and what the construction is going to do
is the verifier is going to send a
sequence of random bits to the prover
um and the total number of bits that
it's going to send is n Prime Times n
where n is the length of the uniform
random string uh in the nizzit
construction
and N Prime is like the number of times
that we're going to repeat this
Construction in parallel
and what the prover is allowed to do is
the prover is actually allowed to choose
its own
um random string of length n it can
choose it how it's supposed to choose at
random but it can choose a hover at once
and it's going to xor this uh random
string uh block by block into the N
Prime blocks that were sent by the
verifier
and once it xores those it's going to
get um
these purple blocks here and each of
these purple blocks can be viewed as a
URS for the nizzic and then the prover
is just going to send the corresponding
proofs Pi 1 to Pi n Prime for each of
these
um different urs's
and then the verifier will check that
all of these proofs verify and if all of
them verify will output one otherwise
output 0.
um so how does this uh transformation
work so uh how do they argue soundness
um so to argue sadness they note that if
you fix these uh red bits of the prover
then the probability over messages of
the verifier which are just random
strings
that all of the urs's uh are bad is
going to be
um Epsilon to the N Prime
where Epsilon is the failure probability
of a single
um a single run of the uh
um
of the nizik and so by Union bound the
probability that all of these purple
uruses are bad for any choice of
um of red bits is going to be at most
two to the N times Epsilon to the N
Prime
and choosing and Prime sufficient large
is going to make this negligible
okay so that's how they uh prove
soundness uh how do they prove uh
witness and distinguishability so this
is going to be by a hybrid argument
and um in this case
uh it's going to go one at a time
through the N prime number of proofs and
in the I've hybrid the ice proof is
going to be switched from an honest
proof with witness W1 to a simulated
proof and then back to an honest proof
with uh witness W2
and the indistinguishability of
consecutive hybrids is going to fall
from a reduction to the zero knowledge
of the underlying music
so how exactly is the reduction going to
work so the reduction is going to get as
input
um uh simulated proof with CRS tilde and
Pi tilde and it needs to program the ice
block of the CRS the I purple block of
the CRS to be equal to this inputted CRS
which is this pink block
um so how's the reduction going to do
that so the reduction is going to
actually choose these red bits of the
prover in such a way that when you xor
the I Blue Block of the verifier with
these red bits you actually get exactly
this
um pink CRS string and then for that
position uh the approver can also just
send the pi tilde that it got from the
um
as input and then for all of the other
blocks it's just going to run the honest
perverse strategy
um okay so what is the problem with
inefficient provers well the problem is
this part over here in red
so
um running the honest proverb strategy
with respect to the purple CRS for all
the other blocks
um so this is uh no longer going uh to
be efficient and in fact the honest
perverse strategy is going to have a
longer run time than the allowed zero
knowledge distinguisher in the
constructions that we have
okay so you cannot just run honest
prover and then still get a reduction to
the zero knowledge property
so what can we do to try to fix this so
uh one attempt is to just try to provide
all the proofs for the other blocks as
non-uniform advice so the reduction is
going to get all the proofs except for
the US block as non-uniform advice and
then the auth block is going to get
programmed to match the pink CRS and Pie
tilde that it got as input
however that is not quite going to work
um and the reason is that um
we cannot just provide all the proofs as
non-uniform advice because we actually
don't know the other purple strings we
don't know the other crs's ahead of time
and the reason is that even if we fix
the first message of the verifier even
if we fix all these uh blue bits
um
the uh red bits chosen by the prover are
going to depend on this pink CRS that we
get as input so only at the time that
the reduction actually gets its input
which is CRS tilde Pi tilde only at that
time can we actually compute this red uh
string of the prover and only once we
compute this registering of the approver
even if the first message of the
verifier is fixed only then do we learn
uh the crs's of all the other positions
so there doesn't seem to be a way to
just hard code this information uh into
the approver
or into the reduction
um so one another attempt uh can be to
uh to try to somehow make the different
blocks of the proof uh independent so
the property that we seem to need is
that for every eye the ice block
um the ice block of the purple string
should be independent of all the other
blocks
and this will let us fix all the other
blocks and then program uh the ice block
of the purple string when we get our
input
but if we do this it's actually going to
give the prover too much Freedom so the
approver will be able to choose too many
of these random bits
um and then this is going to actually
break the soundness argument from before
um so the solution that uh that we
showed is that we showed that in fact we
don't need full Independence across
these purple blocks in order to make the
proof work we just need to show a type
of almost pairwise Independence property
um so we just have to show that for
every pair of blocks the dependency
across these blocks is small
okay so how do we do that how do we get
a situation where the dependency
um across the blocks is small but the
prover doesn't have enough freedom to
Break soundness
um so the main tool that we're going to
use uh is a design uh which uh was
introduced in uh the famous hardness
versus Randomness paper of Nissan and
wigderson
um and uh a design is going to consist
of a universe of elements so in this
case L is the size of the universe
and the design is going to allow you to
construct n prime number of sets
where each set has size n
and the overlap the intersection between
any pair of sets is at most C
and what we can do with this different
parameter are known but for us it's
going to be good enough to construct
designs uh with Universe size L equal N
squared for constant C and for n Prime
so the number of sets is equal to n to
the C
and the key property that we're going to
need from the designs for soundness is
that the total Universe size L is a lot
smaller uh than n Prime so if you just
naively try to construct these
um you know you can split up your
Universe L into sets of size and by
creating a partition but in that case
your n Prime will be smaller than o so
the key property of these designs is
that the Universe L is a lot smaller
than n Prime
and for the reduction to be able to
succeed for the computational zero
knowledge property to work or
computational witness and assumability
property to work what we need is that
the overlap between any of these two
sets is small
um okay so let's see how we will plug
this into our Construction
so uh it's going to look very similar so
the verifier is going to be sending a
random string to the approver each of
the random strings is each block of the
random string is length n where n is the
length of the URS in the underlying
music
um but and we're still going to be
sending n Prime
of these sets
but now we're going to set parameters
differently so we're going to choose a
design uh which is this like grid over
here that the um or the universe of the
design is this grid that the prover has
over here and uh the universe size uh in
this example is uh 16. the set size n is
6 and the intersection size C is 2 and
the number of sets that we're going to
be constructing
um and Prime is six
and now what we're going to do is the
proofer is not just going to xor
its entire grid uh into the
random string sent by the verifier it's
actually going to choose which bits to
xor into each of the N Prime crs's
according to the sets of the design so
these red and yellow bits are the first
two sets of the design
then we have a green set a purple set a
light blue set and a yellow set
and then once we have xored each of
these uh so the prover is going to
choose the bits corresponding to the
entire universe L and then it's going to
xor them into the string sent by the
verifier and it's going to get n Prime
different crs's and then for each of the
crs's it's going to use the prover from
the underlying music to generate a proof
and it will send all those proofs over
to the verifier and the verifier will
verify all of them if they all accept it
will output one otherwise output 0.
um so how are we going to um to argue
um soundness so in this case uh the
approver has more freedom the Pervert
can choose uh 16 different random bits
but if we fix the
um the random bits that the prover
chooses the probability over the first
message of the verifier that all the
crs's are bad is going to be Epsilon to
the N Prime just like before
um and now again we're going to take a
union bound but now we're taking a union
bound over 2 to the L uh different
things uh and we're still going to be
able to make this work because the
properties of the design are that uh the
size of the universe L is actually a lot
smaller can be a lot smaller than n
Prime
and so this can parameters can be set to
make this negligible
um on the other hand we're now going to
be able to argue witness and
distinguishability even though we have
uh inefficient provers so how is this
going to work so we're going to do a
similar uh hybrid argument as before
um and in the I hybrid
um
we're going to assume right now that
we're switching this uh this last proof
here
from uh some witness W1 to another
witness W2
and what we're going to be able to do
now is we're going to actually fix the
entire the bits corresponding to the
entire universe of this design we're
going to fix everything except for the
yellow ones because the yellow ones are
the set that corresponds to this last uh
this final proof over here
and the property of the design tells us
that
um once we fix the first message of the
verifier for each of the N Prime blocks
corresponding to the N Prime different
crs's there is actually in this example
there's only two bits that are unknown
so after you fix everything except for
the yellow bits there is only two blocks
that are unknown in each CRS so for
example
um in this red string there is actually
only two bits of this red string that
intersect with the yellow string and so
um in the pre-processing stage in the
non-uniform advice everything can be
known except for these two yellow bits
okay and in general
um you won't necessarily have two but
you'll have some constant c number of
unknown bits
so why is this good so what this is
going to allow us to do is that in the
non-uniform advice
we're actually going to pre-process four
different possible honest proofs for
each of the blocks corresponding to the
setting of the bits that intersect with
the yellow set so for example in this
first red set we're going to assume the
CRS can be one of four things and for
each of those four things we're going to
pre-process approve and then hardwire it
into the Circuit of the reduction
um okay and so now in the online phase
so that was all in the pre-processing
phase in the online phase the reduction
is going to actually get its input which
is crstilda pi tilde and it needs to
program the icrs to be equal to the pink
value
in order to do that it's going to have
to set these yellow bits
and that is then going to set at most
two bits of each of the other uh crs's
and now we can just use those two bits
that we just set in order to select the
correct uh one out of four honest proofs
for each of the blocks
um
okay so that um that's basically uh the
construction so
um so we were able to push all of the
inefficient
um everything the inefficient prover had
to do we were able to push into the
pre-processing stage except for uh doing
this selection of one out of four proofs
or uh one out of two to the C proofs
given the C uh bits of the
um of the CRS that are revealed during
the online stage
um okay so
um it turns out that uh not only
um do we get
um an efficient reduction of polytime
reduction but actually the reduction uh
in each hybrid step is
um an nc0 circuit
um
plus running the uh running the
distinguisher for the nizik
so that means that given uh uh sorry a
distinguisher for witness and
distinguishability for this app so that
means that given a wi distinguisher in
certain circuit class F uh we obtain a
music distinguisher and class
um f composed with nc0
um okay so I guess I probably
have enough time to
discuss the fine-grained music
um so in the paper we also considered a
fine-grained regime so right now I've
been talking about polytime uh verifiers
and super polynomial approvers but we
also considered a fine-grained regime
and kind of the cliff notes of this
definition is that now the prover is
polytime
um but the verifier the uh zero
knowledge simulator and the zero
knowledge distinguisher are all going to
be in some smaller circuit class f
um and
um
yeah I guess that's what this uh this
definition says in symbols so uh
we have indistinguishability against
um circuits in F from these two
distributions where the first
distribution is the honest generation of
the URS and the honest generate
generation of the proof uh and the
second distribution is a gener a
generation of a URS and a proof by a
simulator and the simulator itself is in
this circuit class f
um okay and now uh we can observe that
our transformation from before also
works in the fine grain setting and so I
didn't Define it but it can be used to
achieve a certain notion of uh
fine-grained uh zaps that we also
introduced
so uh given a music verifier circuit the
verifier Circuit of the zap that we
constructed uh basically just runs uh
the verifier in parallel
and takes an and
given a witness uh indistinguishability
distinguisher circuit for the zap uh we
saw that uh the reduction constructs a
distinguishing circuit for the nizik
um that is basically just the witness
and distinguishability circuit
um composed with C Prime where C Prime
is an nc0 circuit
so we can instantiate this uh
transformation from fine-grained nizik
to fine grains up for the case of nc1
so assuming that Pi is an nc1
fine-grained
non-adaptive nizzic proof system in the
URS model then our transformation is
going to yield an nc1 fine grain zap
um okay so I guess I'll finish up with
uh future directions so
um
one question is just whether this design
based technique can be useful for other
interactive protocols or other settings
where we have parallel repetition
um it seems like it can maybe be used to
um
avoid complexity leveraging or just
somehow make the reduction more
efficient
than uh if you don't have this technique
um and then this relates to
um kind of higher level uh complexity
questions
so
um we have this notion of zaps with
sub-exponential time provers but
actually we don't know a lot about how
it relates to other
um
other Primitives so for example we don't
know whether the other direction holds
so do zaps with sub-exponential time
provers and one-way function
imply nizik in the URS model with
inefficient Proverbs so this implication
holds with efficient Proverbs but not
clear what happens with inefficient
provers because the fls Paradigm doesn't
seem to help here so the fls Paradigm
adds kind of a trapped or witness and
the simulator runs an honest prover with
respect to the chapter witness but in
our case the
um
the honest prover is inefficient and so
this would give you an inefficient
simulator
um and then I guess another question
relating to
um also the the last talk before this is
um
can zaps for NP with some exponential
Temporaries be constructed from a
one-way function
so we can get it from one-way
permutation we don't know how to get it
from one-way function if we got nizik in
the US model from when we function then
it would immediately using our
transformation also
imply zaps
um however due to the above it seems
like
um
zaps uh in this uh inefficient prover
regime may be weaker than nizik in the
URS model so it might actually be easier
to attack this question and try to
construct
um
these zaps for NP
um with inefficient improvers from
one-way function
okay so that's all I've got and happy to
take any questions
okay
some questions
[Applause]
and I hope everybody was in the room